welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special temporary primary host of the
show and today i am joined by greg
knuckles as you know he is currently the
permanent guest co-host of the show greg
how are you doing doing well how are you
i am doing great uh we have
a fantastic episode today really nice
outline a very full outline so we'll see
what we can get to but before we get
there
a few announcements uh as always if you
like the show and you want to support it
there are many ways to do that you could
like rate or subscribe
wherever you get podcasts you can use
our discount code sbs pod at
bulksupplements.com that will get you a
5 discount
uh off your entire order
and that five percent discount uh
conservatively could
end up being about a hundred grand a
year us dollars you put that into
a number of skyrocketing alternative
currencies and crypto coins all of a
sudden you quit your job it's just a
completely different life
so that that seems nice uh you could
subscribe to macro factor that is our
diet app that we put together it does
have a free trial so you can take it for
a spin see if you like it
we believe and hope that you will like
it if you give it a try
and
also greg and i are co-authors of the
mass research review
and this is a special time of the year
for mass because
our big anniversary sale is coming up uh
and this sale actually marks the
five-year anniversary of mass
so we're about halfway through volume
six
been in operation for about five years
now
and so in order to commemorate that
anniversary we've got a big sale
we've also got a best of issue
that just went up on the website a
couple days ago so if you go to stronger
by science.com slash mass best of
there's a hyperlink in the show notes
you can find
our
hand-selected
collection of articles from the past
year that we think are the best stuff
we've put into mass
it's always challenging trying to pick
like you know we each get a couple
articles we get to select
uh it's always hard to try to pick out
which ones make the cut for the best of
issues so check out the best of mass and
if you like it definitely consider uh
subscribing during the big sale they are
going to be our best prices of the year
the sale is going to be from tuesday
april 26 through tuesday may 3rd so it's
one week
and the pricing like i said the best
prices of the year it's going to be 21
per month for new subscribers
209 per year or 6.99 for the lifetime
subscription those are all in us dollars
and
if you're an
existing subscriber and you want to get
in on some of the sale prices you can
upgrade to a lifetime subscription uh
during the sale for only 5.99 us dollars
uh all right road to the stage how's it
going road to the stage is going good uh
as of today
called my shot last episode said i was
going to be in the 220s by
by the time the next episode came out it
is now monday and i am
229.4
which is which is good i like to see
that
it's been
approximately 10 years since i've been
in the 220s uh
did my last powerlifting meet at 220 in
like june
no i think in august july or august of
2012
and by
uh like april may of 2013 i was in the
242 so i'm pretty sure i i got into the
230s uh in the fall of 2012 sometime
haven't seen the 220 since so it's it's
good to be back
and have some some cool milestones
coming up so uh when i hit 228 that will
be
uh 50 pounds down from from my zenith uh
started this whole process at 278 so
that'll be cool
and
i'm trying to get down below 200.
so uh
226 will be the two-thirds waypoint uh
between where i started and where i'm
trying to go
uh so
yeah i'm i'm looking forward to uh the
milestone well i'm happy about the
milestone i just reached looking forward
to some of the milestones coming up uh
and right now
the the diet fatigue is uh is really
starting to set in
and uh metabolic adaptation is kind of
doing its thing like
current calorie levels pretty low
don't really want to keep rolling with
them for the next several months without
a break so what i'm planning on i think
for now is to get down to about 225
and then press pause on road to the
stage for
i don't know month or two just until
my energy expenditure starts creeping up
again start feeling better
but yeah i mean stoked to hit this
milestone
and i
i came to this decision last night about
the uh the potential break at 225 and
the more i think about it the more i
like it because i i could definitely use
a break
but yeah things are things are going
good that's awesome man congratulations
on your progress i'm excited to see
just from like looking at your data how
that diet break is going to treat you
you know because
you've talked about in the past how
uh
it's been informative to kind of watch
your total daily energy expenditure
estimate and macro factor kind of trend
down a little bit as metabolic
adaptation starts to really sink in
but it'll be interesting to see how that
reacts after kind of a prolonged diet
break so
uh that that'll be something for us to
look forward to how is the uh how's the
road to the state or uh road to athens
um i'm glad you asked because i don't
you know sometimes when things are going
too well
it seems like we're just up here
bragging and gloating about it so while
you
succeed uh
and are just killing the road to the
stage i want to level that out i want to
balance that out by just you are being
killed by the road to athens i i am um
and for a little context like you know i
did run into a little uh kind of overuse
thing early on where you know my pop
lydia's muscle was unhappy but
that was just you know too much trail
running too quickly and it wasn't a huge
obstacle you know that cleared up is
back on you know
back on the road to athens no big deal
what i've run into this time i've kind
of alluded to it in previous episodes uh
it's kind of a bigger roadblock so i was
having uh some issues with my hip that
have been going on for like
probably five years at this point
and
as a stubborn person i have not sought
any help or treatment with that which is
not a good way to approach things
but um but yeah so one of the reasons
that i was kind of interested in getting
more into running was because i was just
sick of
you know
pushing and pushing and pushing with
lifting and just keep running into this
hip issue so i was like oh running
should be a little bit more manageable
and this damn hip is interfering with my
running as well so
i'm finally seeking uh physical therapy
i actually made an appointment this is
going to be my first time ever working
with a physical therapist believe it or
not nice uh have you ever worked with a
physical therapist i have yeah
i i've never had the uh the pleasure but
i am looking forward to it because if
nothing else i just want to figure out
what the hell is wrong with my hip you
know it's been five years of disrupting
lifting sleeping now running and i'm
like it it's time to do something yeah
you know so so i'm excited to see how
that will go in the meantime as i've
mentioned previously it's warming up so
i'm going to be able to do more swimming
and more paddle boarding
but i am a little bit concerned that at
the age of 31 i am now kind of
uh
my list of doable exercises is getting
to that point that i didn't think it
would get here until i was in my like
70s or 80s yeah where it's like i can
bob around to the water a little like
you know do some water aerobics maybe i
thought i would have more on the table
at 31 and so i'm hoping that with
physical therapy we can open that up a
little bit open up the uh the
metaphorical playbook when it comes to
exercise so we'll see how that goes
sounds good man i i wish you nothing but
the best with uh with that endeavor
thank you yeah and i'll update everybody
and uh hopefully have a great uh
physical therapy experience and and
that'll encourage people to not wait
five years like i did maybe uh before we
move on i did want to mention i forgot
to mention this in the introduction we
have a new article up on the website
strongerbyscience.com the title of the
article is building muscle in a caloric
deficit context is key so this is a
republished article from mass that kind
of coincides with the best of mass issue
and coincides with the sale just to kind
of give you a little glimpse into what a
mass article looks like this is an
article that i wrote
and one of the reasons we picked this
one to put out for free at
strongerbyscience.com is because it is a
question that comes up so much
it's so common to see online discussions
about uh you know is it even possible to
build muscle in a caloric deficit if so
what's the best way to approach it who
can really do this feasibly uh so this
article talks about who actually can
really achieve this goal of building
appreciable muscle mass while losing fat
uh and in what scenarios it's most
likely and how to actually go about
doing it so if those topics interest you
be sure to check out that article on the
site what was that the article about the
uh the murphy meta
um
i'm gonna click on it okay refresh my
memory here
yes it was about the uh the meta
analysis and meta regression by murphy
and colleagues published in 2021. yeah i
i remember that article it was it was a
good article thank you
all right uh
research review time yeah i mean
normally the uh temporary primary hosts
would kind of facilitate that and move
the show along but uh you know i'll
review the documents and see if i signed
away that privilege
uh yeah uh so research review what do
you got
yeah so uh
i'm doing i'm doing a little research
review uh related to not dying
so
there's a pretty common question that
comes up in the stronger by science
subreddit facebook group uh something i
get asked on instagram a lot just you
know everywhere this this is something
that the people want to know
so people will ask something along the
lines of like hey you know i
i've done the power lifting thing i've
done the bodybuilding thing maybe i
lifted for a sport that i played
previously and you know now i'm just
playing the longevity game
i i enjoy resistance training i want to
keep doing it but i'm not necessarily
attempting to
maximize my strength gains i'm not
necessarily attempting to maximize
hypertrophy i just want to know
how i need to train and how much
training i need to do
to
accrue
the health benefits from resistance
training you know under the assumption
that the amount of training you need to
do to be an elite strength athlete is
probably
a bit more than the amount of training
you would need to do just to to maximize
the health benefits you could accrue
from resistance training so
you know that that's something that is
on a lot of people's minds
and
previously when i answered that question
uh
i would basically just say like you know
here are the acsm's guidelines uh you
know they say do i think like two to
three sessions of resistance training
per week with like one to three sets of
however many reps i don't remember for
for all major muscle groups and boom
that should get the job done and it
doesn't look like all that much
resistance training uh and there wasn't
really great like dose response research
on this question uh well there was i
just hadn't looked that hard for it um
but you know my my basic question you
got to use the
the the little caveat that gets you out
of trouble which is to my knowledge yeah
there wasn't a lot of research yeah i
mean so um
yeah that is true
i am not aware of research that's what i
always say yeah i mean it was just a
question i hadn't looked into that much
because
it didn't interest me personally quite
as much
and also it wasn't as directly relevant
to the people that that i train and have
trained like most most of those folks
are more interested and like hey i just
want to get as strong as possible um
but a
recent systematic review and
meta-analysis came out that is very
relevant to this question uh and it's
actually covered in a research brief in
the upcoming
may issue of mass so you guys are
getting a bit of a sneak peek but for
the complete breakdown check out the
forthcoming issue but uh it is a
a meta-analysis by mama and colleagues
that is the author's surname uh title is
muscle strengthening activities are
associated with lower risk and mortality
in major non-communicable diseases a
systematic review and meta-analysis of
cohort studies
so this was a meta-analysis so it
started with a systematic literature
search as all metas do
and so they were looking for studies
that met these four inclusion criteria
first the study needed to employ a
prospective observational design so
to be clear this isn't it didn't include
studies that can be used to establish
causation they don't use randomized
control trials uh prospective
observational studies are basically just
you know you recruit a large cohort of
people generally several thousand people
and uh just you know ask them questions
like hey do you do resistance training
do you eat veggies do you smoke whatever
like you you gather information about
them and do so periodically over a
matter of years and just observe what
happens to them so you know do
people who
engage in resistance training
do they
die
less frequently
than people who don't do resistance
training do they develop cardiovascular
disease at lower rates etc
so again observational studies not rcts
uh the studies needed to have a minimum
of a two-year follow-up period so
basically you know if you just observed
a cohort for three months it wouldn't
meet these inclusion criteria it needed
to be a long enough period of time for
health related events to actually happen
and the study needed to
to be included in the meta studies
needed to examine the relationship
between resistance training and the
outcomes of interest which were
mortality and non-communicable disease
incidence rates and mortality rates um
and the the studies either just needed
to look at resistance training or a
combination of both resistance and
aerobic training
and the fourth criteria was just that
the study needed to be published in
english which is pretty standard uh so
they found all of the studies that met
those inclusion criteria there were
seven of them i believe uh and they
they analyzed the data three different
ways first they just started with kind
of binary meta-analyses so
um you know do people who engage in
resistance training uh have lower rates
of all-cause mortality than people who
don't so just
do you resistance train yes no binary
variable boom that's it um
then the second set of analyses they did
were dose response analyses so in
studies that reported
not just did people do resistance
training but also how much resistance
training did they do they looked to see
the relationship between how much
resistance training someone did and the
outcome variables of interest
and then the third set of meta-analyses
they did were
basically looking at
the outcomes of interest so all calls
mortality and non-communicable disease
risk
and their relationship with resistance
training and isolation aerobic training
and isolation and a combination of both
resistance anaerobic training to see if
one versus the other form of exercise
was driving the associations observed
or if the combination of both might be
more beneficial than either in isolation
so
that is how they analyzed the data so
just starting with the the
simplest meta-analyses that they did
just the binary analyses
they found that
people who engaged in resistance
training had lower
significantly so statistically
significantly lower
rates of all-cause mortality
cardiovascular disease incidence total
cancer incidence and diabetes incidents
than people who did not engage in
resistance training
and for all of those outcomes
the
the risk the the um the relative risk
was
like
12 to 17 percent lower so like a 15
reduction for all cause mortality 17 for
cardiovascular disease 12 for total
cancer and 17 for diabetes so you know
uh
depending how you look at it
uh the way i interpret that is
relatively small reductions in risk so
we're not talking about 90 reductions in
risk or anything like that but
relatively small but notable and
consistent reductions in risk so not
only do the pooled effect estimates
suggest a reduction in risk of all of
these things but the figure in the paper
indicates that for all of the individual
studies that were included in this
meta-analysis the point estimate for all
of them suggested a reduction in risk so
this was a
a pretty reliable observed effect in all
of the studies that met these inclusion
criteria
which is good to see
then i'm going to skip
the the dose response meta because that
is where we're going to spend most of
our time uh and skip on over to the uh
the analyses looking at resistance
training alone aerobic training alone in
a combination
so there were enough studies looking at
all-cause mortality cardiovascular
disease mortality total cancer mortality
and colon cancer incidents to be worth
analyzing and i'll note uh i wouldn't
put
all of my eggs in in the basket of
just taking these results at face value
because
a lot of the studies that were included
in this meta were
not looking at these specific outcomes
separating out both resistance and
aerobic training so the the previous
analyses i mentioned had like seven
studies going into them all of these
just had three or four studies and each
or uh two or three studies in each
analysis so
quite a bit lower power much wider
confidence intervals so
you know these are these are kind of
more
more up in the air but the
overall trend
is that the reduction in all of those
outcomes i mentioned all cause mortality
cardiovascular disease mortality cancer
mortality and colon cancer incidence
the point estimate
for the relative risk reduction with
both aerobic and strength training
combined
was larger than the relative risk
reduction with either aerobic training
alone or resistance training alone so
for a lot of those outcomes the
difference between those three
categories wasn't statistically
significant because like i mentioned not
as many studies
separated out aerobic and resistance
training to be able to
analyze things on this granular of a
level but at least the point estimates
suggest that maybe a combination of
aerobic and resistance training a little
bit better than either form and
isolation which is good to see
and then finally the the dose response
stuff which i think is
is the most relevant to the people who
ask this question and are interested in
this like you know hey if i just want to
be healthy how much resistance training
should i be doing and i also think that
this is
uh maybe the
the most potentially controversial set
of analyses
so i'm going to tell you what they found
and then we're going to talk about it a
little bit more so there were enough
studies to get rough dose response
relationships between training duration
and
all cause mortality rates
incidents of cardiovascular disease
incidence of total cancer and incidence
of
developing type 2 diabetes
and what they found
is that for all cause mortality
cardiovascular disease and total cancer
there was a roughly j shaped association
such that doing some amount of
resistance training was associated with
lower risk
for those outcomes but
past a certain point
continuing to do more resistance
training was associated with elevated
risk in those outcomes and for all of
them the dose response relationship is
roughly similar so
it seems like doing roughly 30 to 60
minutes of resistance training per week
which i'll note not all that much
resistance training
that is roughly the amount of resistance
training that was associated with the
largest reductions in risk in all of
those outcomes
and passed about
130 140 minutes per week so like two two
and a half hours past that point uh
further increases or
further amounts of resistance training
per week was actually associated with
elevated all-cause mortality rates uh
cardiovascular disease risk total cancer
risk and then like i mentioned the last
outcome they looked at was diabetes
and they found for that basically that
you you kind of reach a point of
diminishing returns after about 60
minutes of resistance training per week
so
relatively large reductions in diabetes
risk
up to about 60 minutes per week and then
further reductions past that point but
the
rate at which risk was reduced uh
decreased as the amount of training time
increase so basically you know if you do
an hour of resistance training per week
versus none that's associated with a
relatively large reduction in risk if
you do
four hours instead of one hour that is
associated with an even greater
reduction in risk
but uh
not not as as large as the slope was
from zero minutes to an hour if that
makes sense so that that's basically
what they found
and so the
obviously the most
glass half full interpretation of this
is like you know what
for for higher resistance training doses
we're just going to assume on faith that
those are spurious correlations and that
everything's good uh but we're going to
take the good part of these findings and
say 30 to 60 minutes of resistance
training per week that is the largest or
like that is clear that clearly seems to
be associated with uh reductions in all
caused mortality rates cardiovascular
disease cancer so we're going to take
that and say yeah 30 to 60 minutes
that's all you really need but also say
and you know what you can actually do as
much as you want and that's totally fine
those potential elevations with that
j-shaped curve that's totally spurious
don't even worry about it um that would
be
that's what i want to believe that's
kind of like the the motivated reasoning
interpretation
um and that would be great news because
like back in the day i did an internship
uh
at like i did some hours at uh an
assisted living facility and i remember
at the time like uh the um
individuals who lived in the facility
i was at the gym you know it was an
exercise science degree so i'd be in
there and you know they'd come in and
you know maybe
one or two times a week when they were
watching the news they'd come do some
some resistance training
and at the time i remember thinking like
that that's such a minimal amount of
resistance training like it was almost
like
my
my intuition led me to wonder like
what's really the point of getting in
there and doing you know 30 60 minutes a
week yeah so for people like that you
know that particular finding is is
really positive really really
encouraging
yeah so i
i actually think i am willing to accept
that part of the glass half full
interpretation um
for a couple reasons one is just that
like i looked into
uh several of the individual studies
that went into this meta-analysis and
they
all observed basically the same thing
that
you know people who did
you know get to the gym do some
resistance training just once or twice
per week less than an hour of resistance
training
in in the studies that fed into this
meta-analysis
that was consistently associated with
reductions in risk like it wasn't just
like a j-shaped curve that's just kind
of a statistical artifact that came
about when you feed all of these studies
into a meta-regression model so that
that was a very consistent observation
and
um you know
doing a little bit of resistance
training over a longer period of time
that is something where there there have
been like longitudinal
studies on so not just observational
studies in community dwelling older
adults
and those studies don't tend to involve
a super intensive resistance training
intervention uh but you know they're
they're looking at mortality rates but
then also just like maintenance of
activities of daily living and and
there's a ton of studies on that and
most of them find like yeah you take
community dwelling older adults you have
them lift a couple days a week nah that
tends to improve health outcomes pretty
much across the board um like
that's on pretty much everything you
look at it seems to have neutral to
positive effects so i do think that
there's a causal relationship there like
older adults do a little resistance
training
outcomes across the board for pretty
much everything will probably be better
than had you not been doing any and it
doesn't seem to take all that much
um
but then you know kind of the more
controversial part is the right side of
that curve so
uh are there increased uh risks of all
cause mortality cardiovascular disease
and cancer if you're doing more than two
two and a half hours of resistance
training per week
and like i said it
it would be nice to just be able to
dismiss that out of hand and say yeah
this must be a spurious correlation we
know resistance training is good for you
there's no way that this
uh association could
possibly be indicative of possibly like
an underlying causal relationship
but i i do think it's worth taking
seriously but i think it's also worth
contextualizing so
in cohort studies that are looking at
all calls mortality
they're primarily using cohorts of older
adults
uh which makes sense you know if if
you're interested in the association
between
some behavior lifestyle factor and dying
and you want to be able to reliably
detect that effect or association
you need a fair number of people to die
in your study between enrollment and
follow-up
and you don't get that if you're
studying 20 30 year olds so
most of these studies use older adults
and so uh you know here here is a
potential explanatory chain i'm not
saying this is for sure what's happening
but i do think it's at least plausible
so
you know it could be that for older
adults people in their 60s and 70s um
you know
with with everyone doing resistance
training there is some level of training
stress
that you can
adapt to productively you put stress on
your body your body adapts to it you
come back bigger stronger than ever
things are good and then there's a level
of stress past which you can't
productively adapt to anymore uh and you
know the the nomenclature typically
given to that is over training but
basically you're just putting more
stress on your body than it can cope
with and instead of getting stronger and
more robust it starts breaking down bad
stuff happens
and so it's entirely possible that with
older adults
the point past which training tips over
from being productive to unproductive
and potentially deleterious it could be
like a pretty reasonable amount of
training so not five six hours a week
but maybe two two and a half hours per
week um
so you know older adults already have
higher baseline levels of oxidative
damage inflammation
it could be that once they're doing more
than two two and a half hours of
resistance training per week again on
average like i'm sure it varies person
to person but on average two two and a
half hours of resistance training per
week that may be more than their body
can can cope with and adapt to and
instead of having a
overtime net reduction in inflammation
and oxidative stress maybe it's causing
net increases which might accelerate the
overall aging process
leading to
increases in all-cause mortality and and
non-communicable chronic disease risk
that i'm not saying that is for sure
what's happening but that is at least
one plausible explanation for these
findings that i think is worth
considering and taking seriously however
there are
alternate explanations so one
uh is just that
resistance training
causally like with pretty much any dose
up to some high threshold uh resistance
training does causally reduce your risk
of all of those things
but it could be that the individuals
included in these cohort studies who
were doing a lot of resistance training
differed from the rest of the cohort in
systematic ways so for example
maybe you get some sort of serious
diagnosis or just some blood work comes
back that looks really really bad and
the doctor says like hey man like you
need to get in shape or bad stuff's
gonna happen and so you know
you say hey my time is running out i
need to do what i can to prolong it i'm
just gonna start working out like a
madman to try to prolong my time on this
earth and so you have
maybe a group of people who were already
in generally poor health doing a lot
more resistance training on average than
maybe people who were doing less
resistance training but were overall in
generally better health and maybe the
resistance training is reducing the risk
in the people who were already at high
risk but they still die at higher rates
just because they were previously in
poor health like again i'm not saying
that is for sure what's happening but
that is another potential explanation um
and there are quite a few
plausible medical conditions where you
could say okay that would really make
sense yeah so it's like hey we
identified that that your bone density
is super low and you know i think i
think a lot of young people
fail to appreciate the severity of a
major fracture when you start getting
into your 70s and 80s i mean like
the oh yeah like if someone just starts
doing three hours of resistance training
per week because they're doing
rehab after a hip fracture like yeah
dude they're
i don't want to catastrophize it but
like that person's in bad shape to begin
with right yeah i mean the percentage of
older individuals who die within one
year of a serious hip fracture is so
much higher than than you would
anticipate you know
um or you know any number of conditions
that lead to frailty muscle wasting etc
for all of those you would tell someone
hey you need to get into the gym extra
yeah so so
uh just to back up your point there are
many many scenarios where you could say
okay yeah that that that does seem like
a plausible explanation
yeah so i i think the way i interpret
this personally
is that if someone asks hey you know i i
want to do some resistance training for
the primary goal of being healthy i feel
very comfortable telling them
that
30 to 60 minutes per week not all that
much resistance training
is probably going to do
almost exclusively good things for you
um
seems to be sell
safe and well tolerated in
the vast majority of populations
reliably associated with reduced risk of
premature death and and a bunch of
non-communicable diseases
so yeah if you want the better safe and
sorry recommendation for like hey i want
to do some resistance training for the
purpose of health uh
do about an hour a week that'll probably
get the job done doesn't have to be
anything crazy uh as far as the right
side of that curve goes
i personally am in wait and see mode i
really want to be able to
reject it out of hand and say ah this is
definitely a spurious association um
but i also
it would be intellectually dishonest for
me to do that because i don't think the
evidence exists
for me to say that is a for sure type
thing like it's it's an association that
exists and we simply don't know
uh like i i think people dismiss
associations out of hand too much like
the the saying correlation is not
causation i think has
poisoned the mind of so many people
where
it it's almost interpreted to mean
correlation
is never causation and it's more just
like hey correlation may or may not be
indicative of an underlying causal
relationship and at this point we see
the association we don't know
if it is causal or not or if it is a
mere association maybe a spurious
association who's to say
so i i'm kind of in wait and see mode
there like i said i i do think that
especially for for younger listeners
like people below
60. you probably don't need to worry
about it because again the cohorts in
this meta-analysis mostly older adults
and so i
i strongly don't suspect that doing 3-4
hours of lifting per week is dangerous
for younger adults
for older adults i would also like to
say that it's totally fine but i
legitimately don't know um so i i do
think that
like i think the way that i would thread
this
is to say
if you're if you're asking me hey how
much lifting should i do if my primary
goal is health i'd say yeah probably
about an hour a week um
if you're an older adult or for anybody
i have for anyone like i think that's i
think that's probably fine yeah um
if
someone came to me and said like you
know hey i've been
doing three four hours of lifting per
week for the last
50 years
uh
you know is
is that dangerous or can i stick with it
um i i think at that point you
[Applause]
i mean at that point i think that's a
conversation to have with your doctor
like i don't i don't feel comfortable
enough
definitely saying that the
increased association with risk from
this meta-analysis
is definitely something you need to be
concerned about and i'm also not
comfortable saying it's definitely
something to not be concerned about so
at higher amounts of resistance training
that's a conversation for you and your
doctor but
relatively low amounts 30 to 60 minutes
per week seems to be associated with a
bunch of good stuff so if if you're
primary lifting primarily lifting for
health uh that is probably what i would
recommend
unfortunately i'm gonna blow a hole in
that hypothetical scenario that you just
laid out because i do happen to have a
friend who is in their 70s
who has been lifting regularly for like
50 years
uh and good luck telling him to scale it
down because that ain't gonna happen i'm
not telling him to scale it down i'm
telling him to ask his doctor if his
doctor thinks he should scale it down
good luck to his yeah actually i've i've
talked to him and uh his doctor was
unsuccessful in those types of uh
conversations but
uh no i think what's really challenging
um with this particular conversation is
you know you want to draw some form of
conclusion that is uh
you know uh actionable and actually uh
chooses some you know number that people
can use
but there are
potential issues
uh on both sides of where you draw that
line right so if you take the
ultra ultra conservative approach that
almost seems like
discouraging older adults from lifting
the way they enjoy
you know you might be putting people to
some extent in harm's way because
they're not accessing some of the
various benefits of resistance training
theoretically
but then if you say oh no go for it
there's clearly nothing here to worry
about then again you know there is
potential for harm on both sides whether
you err
on the excessively conservative side or
the uh excessively uh
less conservative side you know
whichever way you you go with that there
is some theoretical potential for harm
or at least theoretical potential for
limiting benefit you know so that was it
was really challenging like to be candid
when we were uh doing the
the review process internally uh for
your mass article that internal peer
review that we do with all the authors
that was the thing that kept going
through my head was like how do you try
to arrive at a conclusion here that's
can you know consistent with the
evidence but also very cautious about
catastrophizing
the idea of resistance training for
older individuals
so
uh i think you did a great job with it
though it's it's really tough to try to
thread that needle and
um
i i agree like it would not be um
you know like he's i think the way you
put it was intellectually dishonest to
just discard it because it is
inconvenient
it definitely doesn't fit my priors it
doesn't fit my biases i i don't i don't
want that association to exist but it
does and so it's just a question of like
how
how do we handle it right yeah yeah but
um
yeah it's it's uh it would be
you know intellectually
dishonest and incompatible with the at
least intellectually lazy yeah yeah but
but you know it is there and it's
something that that ought to be dealt
with when you're discussing this topic
um
but yeah i i'm also uh when you look at
the
huge
array of health benefits that are
observed
in a more causative manner in the
longitudinal interventions in older
adults it just highlights that challenge
of like well how do we make sure we're
maximizing the benefits we see
in those longitudinal trials while also
being mindful of this uh you know this
correlation that seems to be apparent
you know it's it's challenging stuff
yeah and i i will say
uh one of the things that
um
i don't know like bums me out a little
bit so i i'm like congenitally
anti-authority and i want to believe
that uh
uh
like expert organizations are all just
like dumb and full of [ __ ] and i used to
think that about like the acsm's
guidelines for this stuff but like the
more i look into it the more i think
like ah yeah they were probably right uh
you know couple resistance training
sessions per week hitting all major
muscle groups uh three to five days of
some amount of moderate to to vigorous
uh aerobic activity like
as more and more research comes out like
all of that stuff does seem to be
associated with pretty good outcomes so
unfortunately i gotta give it to him
yeah yeah
all right uh moving on we've got uh
plenty of listener questions that we
want to answer here so i'm going to
start and just kind of go rapid fire
through a few of them and then i'll kick
it over to you yeah go for it how many
were you planning to answer
i don't know
i think it depends on the time um
maybe you do too i do too and then we
can do the
some some of the ones that we're both
going to address cool yeah and i might
do more than two but just because i'm
going like really really quick through
them here which i say every episode and
never do but this is the one and then i
call you out for it and then when it's
my swing i take twice as long as you do
exactly at least we have a system we do
yeah
it's consistent so i've got a question
from kaspars and the question is uh when
talking about pre-sleep protein which
we've mentioned on the show several
times before
uh the question is are we talking about
20 or 30 minutes before bed with a
protein ingestion or are we talking
about two or three hours before bed
and what they're getting at is they're
based on the question they're a little
concerned about this idea of
pre-bed food intake interfering with
sleep quality um you know because our
stomach can get upset body temperature
can be elevated due to digestion which
can be
unfavorable for sleep you know
you want to kind of get your core
temperature down a little bit for for
sleep
so is it really worth sacrificing sleep
quality in order to promote muscle
protein synthesis so as i've mentioned
on previous episodes i think we've
talked about it on the show i'm not
convinced that the pre-bed feeding
opportunity is a unique opportunity i
think as long as you're getting
ideally somewhere between three to six
servings of protein throughout the day i
don't think it's critical to have one of
those be 20 minutes before bed or two
hours before bed i just simply don't
think it matters based on the evidence
available
um
now the question about that trade-off of
let's say it's late at night and you're
like i've only gotten a couple protein
feedings and should i go for it or
should i be worried about interfering
with sleep um you know the question was
what do the studies actually do if
you're looking at the studies that look
at nighttime proteins specifically
impacting body composition those do
provide protein uh relatively close to
bedtime so the most common approach that
you'll see in that small collection of
studies is going to be a protein shake
so it'll be a liquid form of protein
given somewhere between 30 to 90 minutes
before bed somewhere in that time frame
the problem is with those studies
because they're so focused on body
composition they really don't say much
about how it impacted sleep quality it's
kind of up in the air there are a couple
studies i've reviewed over the past
couple years in mass that have looked at
pre-bed protein
you know different types of protein with
different amounts of tryptophan and how
those might influence sleep
because tryptophan is a precursor to
serotonin and melatonin
and so having elevated tryptophan in the
brain at night could theoretically
promote you know a quicker onset of
sleep
in addition to better sleep quality so
for those studies where they actually
looked at sleep quality they uh they did
have it kind of further away from
bedtime we're talking about like two or
three hours before bed so while those
studies give us an opportunity to look
at how this protein is impacting sleep
quality unfortunately it's pretty far
removed from sleep time like i said a
couple hours at minimum and so it
doesn't really get to the root of this
question which is like
should i chug a protein shake right
before bed or is that going to mess up
my sleep so
the research available unfortunately it
kind of takes one of two approaches so
far which is either put it close to bed
and don't measure sleep quality or put
it further from bed and do measure sleep
quality and i don't think that's
intentional i think that's just the way
it goes when you're looking at a body of
literature that is very small and they
they haven't really had an opportunity
to test through all different
permutations of timing and outcome
measurements so i for now would
recommend just using a little bit of
trial and error i think a lot of times
uh sleep disruption related to pre-bed
meal intake can be really complicated so
you want to go to bed you certainly
don't want to be too hungry because that
can interfere with sleep for sure just
ask any bodybuilder that that becomes
one of the hardest things in prep in my
opinion is trying to sleep when hungry
um but you also don't want to be too
full that can be uncomfortable and and
like the uh the question suggests you
know you can have that discomfort of
digestion elevated body temperature
things like that so you want to be
not too hungry not too full
but you also have to consider what does
this meal look like so some of these
studies they'll just give a liquid
protein shake you know very very easy to
digest
and that's quite different from
a very unprocessed meal with a bunch of
fat in it a bunch of fiber intake uh so
the the things that often disrupt sleep
uh when consumed before bed usually a
fatty meal uh especially if it tends to
be pretty spicy that is not a good
combination for a pre-bed meal that
would support really good sleep
but i think a lot of this is very
susceptible to variation between
individuals i think you probably want to
do some trial and error see if a
particular pre-bed meal disrupts your
sleep if it does you might
go for something that's more digestible
you know you might change up your food
sources
or you might change the timing and like
i've said previously if you decide to
just move that pre-bed meal to way
earlier and kind of
uh miss out on that feeding opportunity
immediately before sleep i really don't
think you're you're sacrificing much in
the process
uh another question that i'm just going
to very briefly mention here is from dan
feldman uh you should check him out on
instagram by the way i forget his handle
um it has power lifter is it power
lifter dietitian maybe i think it's
powerlifting dietitian i will i will
verify that as you're talking so dan
feldman great guy check him out on
instagram um he asked if i've come
across any research on cannabis and
specifically thc rather than cbd
and how they impact strength or
hypertrophy and first of all dan shame
on you
uh you shouldn't be asking about this
stuff on the show
but i would encourage listeners to check
out episode 13 of the podcast where i
did a kind of a detailed answer to a
similar question and i talked about thc
and cbd and unfortunately i haven't
really seen a lot of new stuff since
then in terms of peer-reviewed
literature looking at the effects of thc
there was one newer study since then on
cbd
i'm still a little bit unconvinced about
cbd and how it might relate to uh
recovery specifically that's that's
where a lot of the research is is
focused right now uh there's some mixed
evidence but just a general lack of
evidence overall
uh when it comes to thc uh like i said i
mentioned some some of the original
research in episode 13 but just to recap
it seems to be fairly benign in terms of
performance outcomes recovery there are
a lot of anecdotes suggesting that
athletes do use cannabis uh pre
in a percentage of frequency abuse that
i found a little bit surprising or the
prevalence i should say
uh one of the studies i'm going to link
a couple reviews in the show notes for
people who are interested in this topic
um
but one study reported that uh about 23
percent of athletes that were surveyed
reported using cannabis within the past
year um which i thought was pretty high
um but but they mentioned that it was
actually
uh lower than the general population
among people of similar age which
apparently is about 32 percent for
people between 18 and 25 years old um so
just really shocking horrifying numbers
to see the prevalence that high but but
um you know when we look at the
anecdotes you know a lot of athletes do
use it usually they they'll say that
they use it for reasons just totally
unrelated to sport or they might say
yeah it seems to help with just like
resting which kind of indirectly helps
with recovery
you see some people mention that it
helps them sleep better
i've heard people
arguing uh on behalf of
i there's a conversation about removing
it from the national football league uh
drug testing list and the argument that
i saw that was anecdotal was like hey
you've got a lot of
nfl players who are using some pretty
pretty uh harsh drugs to to deal with
pain related to the sport
and their argument was like you should
let them use cannabis and then they can
use that to manage pain instead of some
of these much harsher drugs
again completely anecdotal um i mean
football is already such a violent sport
and based on the documentary for madness
i don't think that putting more cannabis
into the mix would improve that it's an
interesting perspective yeah yeah um but
yeah so anecdotally like athletes
certainly do seem to use it i
doubt that it would be uh particularly
uh ergolytic in terms of strength
hypertrophy recovery um you know the the
one obvious thing is like
inhaling combustion products generally
isn't good for your lungs uh especially
if you rely on those lungs for the sport
that you do so
that's something to keep in mind but you
know unfortunately there's just not a
lot of research here i'll link a couple
reviews in the show notes where people
can dig in and see exactly what's been
done in the research but the short
answer is frankly
not that much
um
also just verifying dan's uh instagram
handle is powerlifter dietitian awesome
checked ann out uh but once again shame
on you dan uh quick question here from
maslin uh
maslin recently heard that creatine
should be taken immediately post-workout
for it to be effective they were
wondering what my perspective is on that
there's uh one or two small studies
suggesting that it might be slightly
more advantageous to consume creatine
post-workout rather than consuming it
pre-workout
the
difference observed in those two studies
was quite small
nothing that would warrant too much
focus or effort or attention when it
comes to creatine i usually tell people
just if you plan on taking it just work
it into your day in a way that is
most convenient for you so that it will
be
you know the biggest issue with creatine
is just forgetting to take it a lot of
people mentioned that oh yeah i'm
technically on creatine but i only
remember like two or three days a week
which isn't necessarily a problem but
i think consistency is the biggest thing
with with creatine rather than timing so
whatever is most convenient for you the
only thing that i would uh add to that
in terms of assessing the best time for
you is keep an eye out about how your
stomach is reacting to creatine so some
people do mention that they have some gi
distress with creatine supplementation
especially at higher doses
if you go to
stronger by science.com
creatine i think that's the yeah that's
the url uh we have a whole section on
navigating what to do if creatine is
causing some gi discomfort but you would
like to continue using it there are some
different strategies about uh you know
when you take it how many doses you
spread it across whether you consume it
with a meal whether you're consuming it
uh with something that's caffeinated
there are a number of different things
you can explore to try to navigate uh
that issue and to try to attenuate some
of that gi discomfort associated with
creatine consumption
uh and then i'll do one more here uh
i've got a question from
georges
how do you say george with an s on the
end
i don't know
george is
i don't know uh but anyway the question
is you're planning on three meals a day
uh in this hypothetical scenario
but you're getting toward the end of the
day and you realize you already hit your
protein target in your first two meals
so it's the end of the day you've got
extra calories left you've got another
meal to eat but you've already hit your
protein target what should you do
and from my perspective there's really
three options here so
option a is stick to your calorie target
have a a low protein meal
and you know just say whatever i already
got my protein in not worry about it
i'll just you know have a carb and fat
heavy meal and and that's that
another option would be
i'm going to you know
force more protein into meal 3 at the
expense of hitting my carbon fat targets
because that that's what we're really
trying to do here is kind of juggle
around protein carbs and fats uh so
option a like i said is
just hit your carbon fat target and let
your protein be low in order to
facilitate that option b would be force
more protein into meal number three so
that it's providing a pretty substantial
third protein dose for the day
and you'd be doing that at the expense
of carb or fat intake so you'd be going
higher on your protein for the day but
lower on your carbs and fats
and then the final option and you you
could add more if you wanted but i'm
just kind of simplifying here another
option is
to
force some more protein into that third
meal and to just go over your calorie
target so keep still aim for your fat
and carbohydrate target as they were
at the beginning of the day but you
would just go over your protein target
and therefore go over your calorie
target
and so which of those three is ideal for
you really just depends on your current
priority and the current goal that
you're pursuing so if you're cutting i
would recommend option a or b when
you're cutting the most important thing
there is going to be making sure that
you're being pretty consistent with your
overall calorie target and so i would
not want to force more protein more
protein in there if it was going to push
me above my calorie target so um that
that could involve just having a low low
protein third meal or it could involve
bumping more protein into meal three at
the expense of carbs and fats but
ultimately you don't want to be pushing
over that calorie target um
if you are
maintaining or you are recomping or you
are bulking but you're really adamant
about staying as lean as pulse as
possible during your bulk
again i would say that a or b would be
the the preferred approaches because
they're going to keep you online with
your calorie target or keep you in line
with your calorie target
if you're bulking but you know it's
something that
you know you really have to mind the
details in order to continuously make
progress so like you're not enjoying
some of those beginner gains when you
first get into lifting but you're
historically a hard gainer
or you're just like really near your
genetic potential or you're just not a
very high responder to resistance
training so for you to gain muscle
optimizing those variables is critical
if you're in that situation i'd say b or
c would be preferable making sure that
you're getting a third dose of protein
because like i said in this scenario
you're a person who has identified that
you know
gains are really hard to come by and so
you really need to make sure you're
getting at least that third protein
serving to make sure that you're
supporting muscle gaining and just
optimizing that process as much as you
possibly can and then of course if
you're bulking and you're just simply
not that worried about a little bit of
fat gain then c would would i think be
the way to go uh you know go ahead and
put a little extra protein into meal
three it'll push you over your calorie
target for the day but really not a big
deal and
that you know whichever situation you're
in this is not something this you know
theoretical scenario shouldn't be
causing a lot of stress um you know if
it happens rarely then by definition
it's not a major problem it's not going
to put your weekly or monthly intakes
way off course um so if it's if it's
happening rarely then by definition it's
not something that's really worth
worrying about too much if it's
happening frequently then that probably
is a sign that you want to go back to
the drawing board a little bit so you
want to figure out
you know why am i consistently running
into this situation and what can i do
to reinforce some better alignment
between my dietary goals my dietary
targets and my actual dietary habits and
so that a lot of times that's when
you're finding that you're constantly
running into these scenarios where you
need a quick kind of like strategy or
work around or i'm in a dilemma here
what do i do when you find yourself in
those situations consistently that's
usually an indicator
that there's some degree of
uh misalignment between your dietary
targets and your dietary habits and so
if you continuously find yourself
in these jams where it takes a lot of
effort to try to find a way out of a of
a problem that comes up that's usually
an indication that you know whatever the
short-term solution is is kind of beside
the point we need to look at the bigger
picture go back to the drawing board and
figure out how are we going to
restructure some dietary habits so that
they're more suitable for the dietary
targets that are in place or how are we
going to adjust those dietary targets so
that they're more compatible with the
dietary habits that you currently use
all right so i think that does it for
the questions i wanted to answer i did a
pretty good job staying staying short
with that yeah that was that was solid
all right uh you want to do one or two
yeah yeah sure where where are we at
time wise uh we are at uh just over an
hour
okay yeah all right uh so
let's see i i
solicited some more questions uh
yesterday from the facebook group and
subreddit there were still some older
questions that i hadn't addressed yet so
i'm going to start with those and people
who re who recently submitted questions
uh i will probably get to those
uh in like the next episode or two
episodes from now but i think i'm gonna
stick with older questions for this one
um so yeah uh feta cheesed from reddit
asks uh why does the strict overhead
press scale so hard with body weight
compared to other lifts particularly the
jerk an open strong man there have been
competitors at the top level that are
competitive using a strict press against
others push presses but this isn't
really a thing in lower weight classes
so why is that
so that's a good question i had never
really considered it before
and so my first thought is hey you know
let's uh
there could just be some selection bias
there uh for all competitive strong men
we don't know what their pr press is
versus their pr jerk so let's try to
find a population where
uh they were training both of those
lifts very hard and we roughly know what
their what their best numbers were and
so there is an ideal place that you can
look for data there and that is the old
school weightlifting records so
these days weightlifting is just
snatching clean and jerk but until
1973 it also included the clean and
press and so to be a really good
weightlifter you needed to be able to be
good at jerking the bar and pressing the
bar uh so we
we have
uh old data
roughly indicating the relationship
between maximum jerk strength and
maximum press strength in elite level
athletes who are training both of those
lifts really hard
for the purpose of competition
and when we look at that
there's not
it kind of there's there's some degree
of interpretation that goes on so you
could look at this data and say
you know what there actually doesn't
seem to be that much of a relationship
between body weight and the gap between
maximum jerk and maximum press so for
example in the 52 kilo weight class
there was like a 12 kilo difference
between the world record clean and jerk
and the world record clean and press
and in the 110 kilo weight class it was
like a 9 kilo difference and and pretty
much every weight class is somewhere
between like a 10 kilo difference and a
20 kilo difference and it doesn't really
seem to vary that much uh but on the
flip side you could look at it and
make the case that maybe the gap is
shrinking
over the body weight range that is
relevant to strong man so
uh for example like the the lightest
like really competitive strong man class
is 90 kilos or like right around 200
pounds there is an even lighter weight
class i think it's like 175 but it tends
to not have that many entrants so you
have a weight class around 200 pounds
you have a 105 class or 231 pounds and
then you have a super heavy class like
those are i think the three most
competitive strong man classes and over
that weight range just looking at at the
records that were set uh there was like
a 12 and a half kilo difference between
clean and jerk and clean and press at 90
kilos uh in weightlifting 110 kilo class
242 there was a 9 kilo difference so a
little bit smaller don't know if we want
to make uh all that big of a deal about
that that slight uh difference but you
know maybe it's indicative of something
and then in the super heavyweight class
there was but a one kilo difference
between the best clean and jerk and the
best clean and press uh of that era uh
vastly alexeyev clean and jerked 237 and
a half and he cleaned and pressed 236
and a half so you know you could look at
that and be like you know maybe maybe
the gap is shrinking for the super
heavies alternately you could just say
hey alexayev was a freak level presser
and you know maybe that's not indicative
of all that much and
i don't know for me personally i
i think that that is the case um
like
i could be totally wrong but like lasha
has clean and jerked
close to 600 pounds
i don't think he can clean and press 600
and i i don't think he could press 600
strictly if he trained for it i could be
totally wrong but i do sort of think
that like uh you know alexayev maybe not
that great of a clean and jerker like
relatively to to modern athletes but
just a tremendous presser so
you know it is a bit of a rorschach test
but i i don't see
in in weight lifters like super strong
evidence that the gap between press
strength and jerk strength really varied
all that much as weight classes
increased
i think i think there may be a little
bit of that going on for reasons that
i'm not
particularly sure about but i think the
bigger factor in play
is just that in the heavyweight class
the weights are so [ __ ] heavy that it
selects
for athletes who are static strength
monsters because if they weren't they
would just zero a ton of events and so i
i think
i think it's just a sport that selects
for people who are just going to be
tremendously good pressers because
they're tremendously gifted for static
strength and you know some of them may
also get a little bit extra out of the
out of a push press or out of a jerk but
a lot of them just don't need it because
they have to be so statically strong to
not just zero almost all of the events
and so i think that
if if i was trying to chalk it up to
just one reason i i think that's mostly
it like athlete selection whereas some
of the lighter classes uh you know
athletes with tremendous
static strength
also do very well but there there are
some more lighter events where more
explosive or faster or more endurant
athletes have more of an advantage um so
yeah i think it's mostly just a matter
of athlete selection at the top level um
but i could be wrong about that but just
just taking a stab at answering that
question i think that is the most likely
explanation
uh lifter in the rye asks uh we've had a
lot of discussion around optimal protein
intake what happens if you massively
under eat protein like let's say i'm 100
kilograms and massively jacked and i
decide to start eating 10 grams of
protein a day do i just implode or what
you probably won't implode um
but
bad things could happen
you will probably start losing muscle
relatively quickly
and you might run into some boutique
issues related to deficiencies in
specific amino acids um
but
more likely than not like the
a very early indicator would just be
that you would likely develop anemia and
so you'd be super fatigued all the time
and then you're really fatigued all the
time you go to the doctor and you say
like hey i feel like [ __ ] all the time
what's going on they say dude you're
super anemic what are you eating oh no
protein okay cool eat some protein so
that's probably what would happen if you
just pushed on through
you have essential amino acids they're
called essential for a reason if you're
just eating 10 grams of protein per day
you're probably not eating adequate
levels of at least one of those
essential amino acids and so just over
time there would be proteins that would
break down need replacing you wouldn't
be able to replace them
and so you know it would it would vary
person to person like what what link in
the chain broke first but eventually
you'd die um but you would become anemic
before you died and and get that
indicator that yeah hey something is
going on that i probably need to do
something about so that is uh
that is what would happen
uh seth markham from facebook asks uh
how much vol how much does one's volume
for a particular muscle affect
positively or negatively hypertrophy for
other muscles i know that's a broad
question but i'm curious what the known
give and take is as far as recovery and
muscle protein synthesis and how one
could potentially elicit more growth in
a specific area by adjusting volume for
other areas so
i
i think that's a great question and it's
an area where
there's not a ton of research but i i
think we can
piece maybe a tentative answer together
so
first off
there is the potential that the
answer to this question is different for
upper versus lower body so i can't
remember the episode but it was a long
time ago like at least a year year and a
half ago um i talked about a study
that
was looking at some
i think i think that study was just
looking at acute hormonal changes uh
with just upper body training versus a
combination of upper and lower body
training
and some of the results indicated that
like uh you know maybe doing some lower
body training puts you in a slightly
more anabolic environment overall
and digging into some of the other
research that has looked at that
question
there is
i would say definitely not conclusive
evidence that doing lower body training
can boost upper body hypertrophy but
there's at least
some
hint
that potentially
training upper and lower body together
might potentially result in a little bit
more upper body hypertrophy than only
doing upper body training again i i am
not
we're far from me feeling very confident
saying that that is for sure the case
but based on the research that exists
like there is
there there is a slight hint that that
might be the case um
and it's hard to say what exactly the
mechanism for that could be could just
be a handful of small studies that that
had some spurious results but you know
there is that hint and then on the
opposite side of things there is there
is a hint that maybe doing upper body
training with lower body training
could potentially
maybe hinder lower body hypertrophy a
little bit uh and so this is even more
tentative so
either last episode or two episodes ago
uh eric talked about the mcnaughton
study that
looked at the muscle protein synthesis
response to
uh 20 versus 40 grams of protein in
people with low lean body mass versus
high lean body mass finding that it
didn't seem in that study like the
people with hyaline body mass maybe
needed more protein to maximize acute
muscle protein synthesis response
then the people with flow lean body mass
but eric cautioned against taking that
like super at face value like yeah you
know there's there's other lines of
research this is just one acute muscle
protein synthesis study not going to
rehash all of that but in that same
study
the
uh so
that was kind of the third study in a
string of three studies that all used
similar designs so you give
you put lifters through a workout and
you give them either 20 or 40 grams of
protein and you see
whether there are differences in protein
synthesis between 20 and 40 grams of
protein
and
the
first two studies only used a lower body
training stimulus and the mcnaughton
study used a full-body training stimulus
but measured muscle protein synthesis of
the quads and when you look at those
three studies together the overall
training stimulus for the lower body
seemed to be roughly comparable the
difference being in the mcnaughton study
people were also doing some upper body
training
and if you just compare those three
studies the elevation in muscle protein
synthesis in the quads in the
mignoletton study
was like 20 30 percent lower than the
elevations in muscle protein synthesis
in the other two prior studies that had
used a similar design and so
i don't necessarily think it's advisable
to compare
different studies with different cohorts
completely apples to apples but if one
were to do that you could make a very
weak case that may be doing some some
upper body training along with lower
body training might reduce muscle
protein synthesis of the lower body
muscles a little bit so if you wanted to
to take the maximally liberal kind of
like
bio hackery like a suggestion is fine we
don't need proof
approach to this you can maybe make the
case that
uh if you want to maximize upper body
hypertrophy you should be doing some
lower body training and if you want to
lower if you want to optimize lower body
hypertrophy maybe you should avoid doing
too much upper body training that that
again is is the maximally liberal
interpretation
my
personal take
is that it probably doesn't matter all
that much um like that that's not
necessarily something that i've seen
play out in practice and again the the
research supporting that interpretation
is very weak and very tenuous
um
but i do think that i i think that it's
mostly just a matter of like overall
dose and a question of whether
the training you're doing for one muscle
group detracts from your ability to
train another muscle group really hard
so talking to
um
like talking to some bench specialists
back in the day one of the things that
they consistently told me is like ah you
know like you got to do lower body
training you don't want to you don't
want to look like a popsicle like huge
upper body walking around on chicken
legs but like you know we we mostly just
do some machine training for lower body
maybe some squats mostly avoid deadlifts
they're like oh why do you avoid
deadlifts and they're like dude if it
fries your upper back you just don't
have as stable of a base to bench on uh
if you're if your erectors get fatigued
and sore you can't arch as well like if
i train the deadlift too hard i just
can't put as much effort into my bench
training as i want and so like by
cutting back on deadlift training that
that improves my bench results like that
that's that's something i've heard from
probably a dozen bench specialists like
a lot of bench specialists don't like
deadlifts and you know that could also
just be motivated reasoning it's like
hey i'm a bench specialist because i
have really short arms and as a result i
also suck at dead lifting so i'm i'm
going to invent a reason why i shouldn't
deadlift but uh yeah that is something
that a lot of bench specialists say and
and i think there is probably something
to that that you know if you want to
maximize
how hard you can train a particular
muscle if there's some other exercise
that detracts from your ability to put
a full level of effort into exercises
that train that particular muscle it
might detract from your results a little
bit
but but ultimately i think i think most
of that is stuff that you can probably
train around um
and i
personally
after laying out the maximally liberal
case for why it may matter i personally
think that it likely doesn't matter
like when you
when you look at the most jacked people
in the world most of them don't have
like
just glaring holes in muscular
development
um and you know even if they have a
particular muscle that may jump out to
you it's like ooh that's underdeveloped
like it's probably still like way bigger
than the average person's like if you
see a huge jacked bodybuilder with tiny
calves their tiny calves are probably
still enormous it's just the rest of
them is is so much bigger um
so yeah like the
it doesn't seem like hugely jacked
people are really missing out on much by
not neglecting certain muscles um
see i i personally don't think it makes
all that much of a difference
uh
let's see those were all of the old ones
let me see if i have time for
one other newer one we're at 118. yeah
okay okay that yeah i'll leave all of
all of the newer ones let's do some
collaborative questions well we have
time for one which one would you like to
do let's do
let's do debating people
oh yeah
yeah
so yeah this is a question that comes up
from time to time and the question is
always just
why don't you debate blank right and and
sometimes they'll i'll get like tagged
in something and hey you two should go
at it uh in a battle of wits and see who
comes out victorious
and wins over the uh the perspectives of
the listening audience and so
this whole approach of debating people
uh you know hey let's get on a youtube
channel let's get on a podcast and we'll
we'll hash it out
it's become really popular like really
common in fitness and in nutrition
um but in my opinion it's a somewhat
lousy way to handle a lot of the
topics that are being debated um
you know
from my perspective a debate is really
useful for discussions about
uh big picture ideas big picture
concepts things that are you know
theoretical
debates related to certain ideologies
things like that
um
most of the you know when it's really
logic driven or really theory driven um
and it's more about
kind of a rationalist perspective of
like well let's put together the logic
here and walk through it i think that
lends itself more to the debate format
but
a lot of times in nutrition and exercise
it's like let's quibble over the details
about what this specific study actually
found and what that means for you know
the question
or the topic at hand
uh and i think a great example of
uh of how to do debate in fitness and
nutrition in my opinion or one that i at
least felt good about
was when we went back and forth with
meadow henselmans about the whole p
ratio discussion we've talked about it
on the show we've got the articles on
the website
it took the form of we will present a
case and then
someone else will kind of you know say
well actually here's what i believe and
you know i think you missed this and
that study and here's a study you didn't
consider it it's written
it takes the written form and it goes
back and forth and that allows the
individuals who are involved in the
discussion to sit through it you know
sit down think through it
go back to the research and critically
read and interpret that research
and see if yeah maybe i did misinterpret
something maybe i did miss something in
the supplementary file that they've
brought my attention to but it's the
type of thing where a lot of times when
you hear these fitness and nutrition
debates on like a youtube channel or a
podcast it's all on the fly
and someone will say this study found x
and the other person will say i disagree
and usually there's not a lot of room
there to to dig into the details and
let's say say well let's pause i'm going
to bring that paper up give me about 10
minutes to dig into it and then we'll
revisit this that that never happens
because that's awful for
the listener or the viewer uh so in many
cases i i think that the debate format
just in terms of an uh
a live in-person audio or video debate i
think it's just not very suitable for
digging into the actual literature and
coming away with the most uh
most accurate most nuanced
conclusions from that literature you
really do have to dive back in
and in some cases
another reason i don't like to do these
is because
a lot of times people go into it with a
completely formed conclusion right so
like
one of the things that that comes up is
like
you see these camps in the nutrition
world whether it's like carnivore or
vegan or whatever the case may be and
it's like there's nothing that's going
to happen in the next 90 minutes that's
going to move me from my position
both of the speakers in the debate are
are completely attached to their
position
and the audience from each respective
speaker is completely entrenched in that
position and there's like this imaginary
maybe real tiny portion of people in the
middle who actually open that up and say
yeah maybe i am open to being swayed one
direction or the other yeah and i tend
to find in my opinion that usually you
get swayed by the person who speaks most
confidently and not by the person who
makes the best actual argument in terms
of the
accuracy and construction of the
argument so for all those reasons
i'm just i i don't find it to be a very
fruitful endeavor in many cases but greg
what do you think no i i agree i think
it's um
so i i think one of the distinctions you
made you made is very important so is
this a debate
about theory where we're using
logical reasoning to talk through
something or is it a debate about
something scientific where we're relying
on sources we're citing and
interpretations of those sources to make
a case
i think those are two very different
types of debates and if it's more of
just kind of like the logical
rationalist debate you can do that in
real time i think most people
or a lot of people still do that in bad
faith but that is at least something
that could theoretically be productive
to do in real time um
but i very much agree that if it's a
debate about something related to
science and evidence i think it's
virtually impossible to do it in real
time
in a debate format
in a way that is
both in good faith and interesting so
uh in the reason i say it's impossible
to do in good faith
or very challenging to do in good faith
is
uh if someone else is is citing evidence
to support their point
you have
you have basically three
uh three options you can do
and two of them are quick and one of
them are slow option one is just to
dismiss what they're saying
which
isn't uh uh debating in good faith i
don't think option two is to just accept
what they're saying which
may be a which is a weak debate tactic
like you're you're just seeding ground
perhaps unnecessarily because you might
need to look at that source for yourself
so you're probably not going to do that
and then the third option is very slow
which is looking at the source reading
it carefully considering it which you
just can't do um in in a live debate
format and the other thing is is
you can do that if and only if both
people
engaged in the debate
intimately know
every source that they are citing and
the other person is citing inside and
out to the point that they can quibble
about the details in real time which
i have never seen that happen so
so that could occur in theory and that
could lead to a productive debate and it
would also be a hideously boring debate
for all of the readers who aren't
intimately
aware of all of those sources inside and
out um
so yeah i i don't think it's ever
like i just don't think it's ever going
to be particularly fruitful um
and
yeah that's yeah like you were saying i
so someone wanted me to debate someone
and i was like this person was just
making the rounds just debating
everybody who would jump on a call
and i went and listened to one of their
debates and and they did kind of exactly
what you're referring to where like
someone brought up a point and they're
like nah that study's clearly fake
because there's and like
you could look into other research if it
was in a written uh
kind of form yeah and you could say well
i question the veracity of that data
based on this other evidence which makes
it look very very questionable but in
real time like you said all it was just
a gut instinct and a hunch and it was
like ah that's fake news and like anyway
let's move on i reject your data do you
have anything else and it was completely
not useful yeah and the other thing that
that happened um
was uh
that the person asserted a particular
point
and the other person was like yeah i've
never seen that in the research i don't
know which research you're talking about
and they're like well it exists so i
mean that's on you
and they just misrepresented it to the
point that even if you knew the study
you'd have no idea what they're
referring to yeah i mean that also um
leads to a difference between written
debates and uh like real-time
talking debates uh which is that when
you're just having a conversation with
someone
it's far easier and oftentimes very
advantageous to simply lie
because like dude if you're
so if it's like a written back and forth
and there's a point you want to make and
you say that there's a study that backs
it up uh but you don't link it and you
had a week to look for it and you just
say like you know what there was a study
that showed x y and z unfortunately i
can't find it a reader can look at that
no like oh they had a week to formulate
this response they're they're full of
[ __ ] like they're they're clearly lying
about this whereas like that's a very
reasonable thing to a certain person
like i saw this study i'm blanking on
the title and author
and
that could be entirely true and honest
like most people don't remember the
title and author of every study they've
ever read or you could simply be lying
and there's no way for for the viewer to
be able to tell the difference um
so yeah like there there's there's a lot
of slimy tactics that work in debates
that
simply don't work in written back and
forth so i i think that it
engenders a level of discourse that's
not great and the other thing i'll say
is as a potential participant
i've never seen
an outcome of the debate
where
someone doesn't wind up getting harassed
like as far as i can tell people who are
very into debates especially like twitch
debates they just have like discord
servers of lackeys and like if someone
disagrees with them it's like oh yeah
just go harass them on twitch go harass
them on twitter uh there's like a 75
chance that like
if you debate someone
uh especially if you seemingly win the
debate and make the other person look
bad there's like a 75 chance you're
about to be mobbed by people accusing
you of being a pedophile i don't know i
don't know how that occurs but
someone always winds up being accused of
pedophilia that's a that's a commonality
of
of virtually all like recent online
debates uh that i've that i've observed
so it gets really toxic like that mob
mentality kind of takes over and then
it's these two factions and yeah some
someone is getting harassed in the
process yeah um but yeah so the thing
like that that debate i mentioned um if
you were just kind of observing you'd
say wow that person made really
confident points that seem to be
supported by
evidence that they say exists
but
you wonder how many listeners took a
second to
find the vague research that was being
alluded to and then say
dude that's not even close to what you
said it it was showing you know within
the debate like if you actually dug into
the resources uh you would find that
this debate was built out of like a
house of cards and just kind of glued
together with like you know
goo
glue and tape and gum and like it was
just a terrible argument that was not
representative of the underlying
evidence but again uh in the debate
format there was no way to actually go
through and fact check uh in a
meaningful way well and i mean like even
even even if there was a way like not in
real time during the debate but just
viewers after the fact you know like the
the person organizing the debate makes
both parties submit all of their sources
link them all in the show notes just the
way people interact with with
information uh like like links in video
versus audio content is very different
like if you're reading an article and
they're linking out to something else
that they claim supports a point that
they're making you just open another tab
you can skim it you can go back to what
you were reading before like that that's
a very normal thing to do um
but you know if someone in a video cites
a source
maybe you're gonna pull it up and like
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna read
that after the video but like i don't i
don't think virtually anyone pauses the
video they're like oh this person cited
a source let's pause the video read the
source in its entirety and then come
back to the video to see what this
person says about it theoretically they
could but like that's that's just not
how people tend to interact with video
content whereas i think
it's more likely that they'll interact
with written content that way
yeah for sure and then my final point
is that due to the road to enlightenment
that i traversed in record time uh
i'm just no longer interested in trying
to insist that people agree with me so
like when people say hey you should
debate this person who disagrees with
you i'm more inclined to say i'd be
happy to
defend any of the content i put out on
this and to consider rebuttals but
that that's kind of where it starts and
ends like here's my perspective here's
why i believe it i'm of course happy to
revise that but the debate not not
really interested
um all right so do you have anything to
play us out i do have something quick
uh if you don't have anything i don't
really have anything all right well um i
am
unfortunately i i must report i i was
hoping to do the second
uh installment of eric's seder stories
which is a fan favorite segment that
we've done exactly once on the show
that that goes all the way back to
season one i think uh my my first ever
seder where this is the third episode of
the podcast i think so yeah but i was at
a seder and i i mentioned i was a
kinesiologist because i never know how
to explain what we do for a living and
someone's like oh cool so you work with
like crystals and gems and and harness
their energies and stuff and it was just
a conversation that really went off the
rails um
i am both relieved and displeased to
share that i went to my second seder
this week
and
no outrageous conversations like that
occurred so it was a pleasant time but
not great for content so shame the one
thing that i took away from it though
honestly um
was you know you hear about people who
take the kind of
uh approach to learning a language where
they just immerse themselves in it right
and they're like yeah i just like showed
up in spain lived in a little town
picked it up over time because everybody
was speaking spanish
i think i understand hebrew less than i
did before the seder honestly i
i don't know if there's something wrong
with my brain where i just the
linguistic part is just totally fused
shut
maybe one of my severe concussions
really rattled that part of my brain but
man immersion is
yeah i don't think that's a viable
strategy for me because i genuinely
think i lost hebrew content in my brain
because
there was all the reading going on and i
i was completely lost but i i would just
kind of sit there and then when
everybody turned their page i'd be like
all right turn your page it'll make it
seem like you know what's going on uh
and and i i think it worked well but
anyway uh
last weekend there are a bunch of
holidays if you happen to celebrate any
of them i hope that you enjoyed them and
i think that does it for this episode of
the podcast so uh as always thank you
for joining us and we will be back soon
with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you